hey welcome back everyone our next
speaker is guillotine from UT Austin and
her talk is how fast his neural in their
tables when deciding between money okay
thank you jennifer it's great to be here
thanks so much Bruno for all your work I
think I'm a nominal Corgan either of
this program but this is like the most
pleasant core igniting experience I've
had because he has shouldered the whole
burden enjoy this as a participant so
it's it's really great and so in the
spirit of keeping with the Symons
workshop theme and to bring together
some perspectives from computer science
and engineering and neuroscience I
thought I'd talk about something a bit
different than I have been really
talking about recently so my major
interest live in you know questions of
short-term memory and very recently the
navigation but you know we've been
working on some questions that come up
actually in many different contexts
including spatial navigation and the
question is about you know estimating
the best option and the time complexity
or the speed with which it's possible to
estimate a good option for many okay so
it's a bit ironic that I'm giving your
talk on decision-making I'm just telling
some friends outside that I'm the worst
decision-makers I guess we study here
pathologies and so my motto in life is
also done defense when I get to it and
so maybe that's why this is a topic that
holds some fascination for me okay so
this is certainly a decision making
problem I think many of us have faced I
faced it regularly and my kids even more
so I love ice cream so okay so what is
this engine making in this context I'm
going to define it very narrowly it's
just going to be a question of you know
you're presented with many options you
know assuming that the different options
have different you know values then how
do you go about the value in each of
them and picking the max and how long is
that gonna take
so this is the question okay so first of
all um when to decision you know
when would you want to compute the max
with your argument max of a set of
options well you would do that you know
anytime you want to do inference for
example in large neural circuits you
might want to complete compute the
maximum likelihood each neuron signaling
something which one is the one signaling
with maximum likely you know which is
the maximum likelihood signal maximum
force Qi action selection etc one can
study questions about how humans you
know in psychophysical experiments do
decision-making you know even in a non
neural context there's social
decision-making that happens and
colonies for example to choose the site
for the next nest for the colony or to
make a decision as foraging ants go out
looking for food sources they come back
and report in the quality of a food
source to the nest and the nest has to
decide how to allocate its resources and
which food source to go out and harvest
and exploit right so the decision units
all these multiple options that are
available and a decision has to be made
one of the problems with having multiple
choices in decision-making is that it
could take a while right I mean how long
and the question is how long does it
take like how does this problem of
choosing the maximum that be many
options take and how does it scale as a
function of the number of options okay
and so why is this question important
again I would say that because it really
you know this max operation is just such
a basic part of so many computations it
occurs again and again in in the context
of many computations you want to know
the time complexity okay and
specifically in the neural context you
know the number of alternatives can be
very very large if you're talking about
inference across the states of a large
number of neurons in one circuit right
that could be in the thousands or tens
of thousands or even hundreds of
thousands right so it's possibly that
one has to do this kind of decision
making across many many many many
alternatives okay and there's some
biological examples there's some
suggestions that maybe there's
winner-take-all dynamics and Kenyan
cells in Drosophila or maybe even in
play cells you know to choose like
sparse representations when all these
neurons are competing to respond and
represent
okay so and I would also argue that you
know one of the things that we think is
a strength of neural computation is its
distributed nature right so if you take
a computation that would seemingly take
a long time and then you make it
efficient by farming it out in a
parallel way to many agents or players
in neurons but then if you want to then
collect the final result in the end or
you know pick of all of these different
things being evaluated you have to
collect the final answer if that takes
order n time you distribute it to n
agents in parallel if it takes order n
time you collect the answer and get the
max you've kind of like lost the game
right after all the computations in a
sense understanding the speed of
parallel computation or for max it's
sort of almost like an essential element
to being able to answer whether or not
parallel computation makes sense in the
brain right so I think it's a very basic
question okay so to answer this question
I'm gonna do it two ways so first I'm
going to consider this deterministic
case and then which is totally unreal
nothing in the world or the brain is
noiseless and so but it sets a stage and
then we'll go to the realistic case
which is the stochastic setting okay so
in the deterministic case okay
so what okay so first let's talk about
just the intrinsic complexity of the max
operation forget about neurons for a
moment okay so you've got a list of n
items okay they're all static and each
one is just some scalar it's just a
number okay I'm going to go through this
list of items and find the maximum
element okay so no serial you know in
like a fun name and strategy like a
serial computer we just go down the list
right one by one so we look at one item
in the list and hold that in memory go
to the second item in the list and then
if the second item is bigger than the
first item ever discard the first item
in memory put the next item in and just
go on down the list right and once it's
done then it knows it notice the max so
the the space complexity sort of like
how much memory needs is like one but
the time complexity said because you
have to work down it has to work down
serially through the end items okay and
now we want to ask then just this is
just a reference point right and so this
is like you know the best you can do
with the serial strategy neural network
you know we distribute it so presumably
we're
send one of those inputs in the list of
one of the items in the list to one of
each neurons one neuron each and then
you know so I'll say that the space
complexity of this is like N and the
question is what is the time complexity
right so can you trade off can you take
this time of n put it into a space and
if that's true maybe you would expect
that the time should be order one it
should be independent of n okay so in
fact that's what we would hope for we'd
say if you have a fully efficient
harnessing of parallelism we would hope
that the parallel strategy is like the
serial strategy divided by N and so it
should be like order one that's what you
know independent of n okay but on the
other hand you know no components are
certain you know they decay over time
they don't maintain you know memories
you know they may also have some noise
on them the question is you know does
that mean that neural computation can't
achieve this fully parallel okay so what
what is the neural network setting for
computing Max and automatics well so the
canonical circuit is called the
winner-take-all circuits I think most of
you know the setup so you can think
about it this way you have a bunch of
neurons it's colored things over here
and each of them receives an input B 1 B
2 etc etc and that's just assumed that
their order to be 1 is bigger than the
rest and the rest be 2 smaller than B 1
and the rest can be the same or smoke
you know someday Ron frenz and
distribution and in this setup each
neuron excites itself so these are the
activations of the neurons X's each
neuron excites itself at some strength
alpha receives us input B sub I and in
addition all the neurons and globally
inhibit each other okay so you can think
about this as like pairwise inhibition
or you can think about all of them
projecting to a single inhibitory neuron
which then globally inhibits all of them
okay so so these are you know just two
equivalent pictures for the same map and
so okay so if for appropriate choices of
alpha and beta specifically if they're
strong enough each then it's possible
under these conditions to get a global
winner-take-all solution where there's a
single winner from this computation
so you see something like all of these
activities here are decay down to zero
one of them goes up and this so I'm
calling are the firing rate and the this
internal variable here X yeah yeah
actually so it turns out that it's
almost independent of the statistics of
be survived analytically in this
deterministic case I haven't told you
the solution yet but analytically it
turns out that the only really important
thing is the Delta which is the gap
between the first two there's a very
weak dependence in the distribution of
the rest of them and so for this talk
because it's short talk I'm just gonna
mostly show you results where the rest
are equal so all the other B eyes are
equal and then there's a gap Delta but
we can talk about the gap dependence
great okay so now okay so so there's
these conditions that allow
winner-take-all dynamics and these
conditions I showed you where this so
you know alpha should be smaller than
one for a unique solution to emerge and
alpha plus beta should be bigger than
one in order for there to be sufficient
competition so that there is at least
one winner and so these are the two
conditions but you can see that these
two conditions means like like you sort
of are free in your choice of beta okay
and so they're two obvious choices of
beta one choice of beta is to make beta
B order 1 over N right because each
neuron is contributing inhibition to the
network if they're n neurons then you
know this way you're just keeping the
total amount of inhibition fixed so you
might want to make it 1 over N so we'll
call that weak inhibition okay so the
total inhibition is of strength 1 or you
can have a strong in addition where you
know each neuron is contributing
inhibition of strength 1 this is like
really strong right and and then right
disorder 1 it doesn't scale with N and
and then you know the total inhibition
the circuit is order n okay and it's not
at all obvious I would say what regime
neural circuits are in I guess I don't
know we could we can talk about it that
would be nice to know sort of what what
what we think is going on ok so this
stuff these are this is a free choice ok
of inhibition strength and the question
is how do things behave so now in this
deterministic winner-take-all setting
I'll just begin to skip to the bottom
line so basic
this is the serial strategy over here so
this is the time complexity of the of
the serial strategy as a function of
network size and as expected it just
grows linearly right I mean that's
that's what I've plotted is grows
linearly and a network with weak
inhibition also has a linear growth in
the decision time with it okay which is
not what we want as bad as a pseudo
strategy okay on the other hand if you
go to strong inhibition then we see that
the benchmark strategy is flat its order
one in time it doesn't scale with N and
in fact the neural network also achieves
that right so the strong inefficient
circuit achieves the parallelism
benchmark okay but weak inhibition is as
slow as your computation okay so all
right so but this is all realistic so
what we really want to do is study the
more interesting case which is
stochastic winner-take-all since the
casick winner-take-all each of the
inputs to the neurons or each of the
inputs items in the list is a is some
mean value plus a fluctuating quantity
that just fluctuates about the mean with
some variance okay over time and the
means are again ordered the same way
okay so b1 is the biggest with a b2 has
a gap in the rest or whatever and now we
can consider again the serial fun
normally strategy and ask what is the
optimal serial strategy if you want to
achieve so by the way now once you
introduce noise you can never get
correct winner-take-all all the time you
can't be guaranteed a perfect dinner
tickle because here the definition of
correct winner-take-all is that you
actually identify the unit that has or
the the the input that has actually the
largest b1 bar but you know you'd have
to average forever to be sure that you
can always get it exactly right so in
stochastic winner-take-all or in
stochastic max when we just has to
choose an accuracy and you have to ask
for the time complexity that I can say
yeah that's right all the neurons are
receiving I Edina mice that's right
that's fluctuating over time okay and so
um the pseudo strategy will be that you
know as you go down the list same way
you just go down the list and you know
look at the element the first element in
the list but now because each entry is
noisy you want to dwell for some time
and you know average get a better
estimate of the I bar when you're
sitting at the ith element and the
question is how long should you dwell at
that at that number too
sure that you get a fixed accuracy even
as n is scaled okay and so using
concentration inequalities you you know
we find that the the amount of time you
should dwell is log n and so therefore
the serial strategy will take time and
times log n dwell time per entry to to
ensure a constant accuracy ok so now our
parallelism benchmark would be that
something that takes order n times less
than the cereal strategy yeah Peter its
logon comes from this yeah it's like
basically you have this distribution you
want to ask that you know there's a
probability of getting it wrong which is
somewhere in the tail of the
distribution to use the concentration
inequalities to do that and that's how
you get the log and it's really generic
I'm sorry it doesn't have to be Gaussian
like it's much more general than that
because it's a concentration and so it's
like Chernoff bounds and hefting bounds
which apply for many many more
distributions think I've seen yet so you
don't have to make a Gaussian ID
assumption at all yeah okay so so the
hope is that one can you know the
question is whether a neural strategy
can achieve a factor n speed averages is
it possible to do this computation in
log n time okay and so now I'm so
there's a problem there's a problem with
winner-take-all dynamics it turns out
with the canonical circuit for the
stochastic maths problem and what is the
problem the problem is well you know we
saw in the deterministic case that the
only hope you have of doing something
efficient is to use strong inhibition
weak inhibition was no good so we're
gonna start there so with strong which
will start with strong inhibition but it
turns out that when you apply this
winner-take-all dynamics with
fluctuating inputs to a network then the
output of the network just remains flat
these are unjust fluctuate around some
zero value and nothing can take off for
and as the network gets large then you
can not find any parameter settings so
this is like you know as noise gets you
know as a function of noise and and and
the regime which has no winner-take-all
dynamics gets big and starts to all the
curves converge Tomos basically no
regime where there's actually a really
to call solution and that's also true as
you change parameter is like
self-excitation there's just not a
solution as you go out asymptotically
larger
again the reason for that is because
really it's strong inhibition you know
when noise is unbiased right it's sort
of fluctuating unbiased way but the
problem is it's being shot through the
non-linearity which is the neuron okay
and so it's rectified and so now it
means that neurons that are fluctuating
are not contributing inhibition to the
circuit and so it's an example of
unbiased suction resulting in a biased
effect which is excess inhibition in the
circuit and so the question is well
let's just go to a weak inhibition so
you can apply you know if you do week in
addition and do the other obvious
scaling which is an admission goes like
when we're in per neuron then it turns
out that there is an existence there are
gonna take all states that exist out to
very large and that we can find or you
know they exist robustly but the problem
is that then it requires really
exquisite fine tuning which is the self
excitation needs to be within 1 over N
over tuned value of 1 which as n goes to
you know infinity but even for large n
it's really it's you know crazy ok and
it's really slow it scales linearly the
time complexity - lines just like the
serial well not not linearly I'm sorry
it scales like basically faster the more
strongly than linearly I mean
asymptotically for large n
[Laughter]
I'm trying to imagine what large n is
and so I was trying to enter really
southern Italian I was trying to draw a
line like so there's something about the
sparsity of the maximum representation
here right so what we're talking about
here is a case where you have a single
neuron that needs to win that's right
right but if I think about real
biological networks and we're never in
that we're always that there's some
distributed pattern which have a certain
level of sparsity that needs to win yeah
and that feels like we're more down in
the ten to the two to the ten to the
three at most yeah so so how concerned
should I be I guess it's a question
that's a great question actually to
perfectly honest we haven't studied like
a winner-take-all time complexity and
that doesn't something we want to do so
we just haven't done it yet yeah but
yeah no that's right no so no it doesn't
help it doesn't solve this problem right
so you see that basically to guarantee a
unique solution we need alpha to be
smaller than one so you would think
you're perfect freedom with alpha here
there's no choice of alpha that's giving
you what you want we yes I can I can
show you offline but here in the weak
inhibition case it turns out actually
alpha is prescribed you don't have
freedom in choosing alpha and then it
has to be in exactly this interval and
this interval shrinking to zero very
strongly with them so this is the issue
and so we can discuss but yeah and in
the weak inhibition case there's no
freedom in choosing alpha strong
inhibition you have freedom in choosing
alpha but doesn't help so that's the
that's the bottom line so I want to be
giving this talk like it this would be
really pessimistic and then you would
not come to listen to me again
so there's there's actually something I
want to present as an alternative model
so what I presented to you is the
canonical model for winner-take-all
dynamics this is a modified model okay
for stochastic Max and Max and it's a
way to take all circuit that actually
has a second non-linearity in the
inhibition okay and the assertion is
that it can solve this large end problem
and so so for example here I'm showing
you the case where the Lin the the
conventional canonical circuit failed
but this circuit wins so the question if
it succeeds as a winner and the question
is what is the dynamics here so the idea
is that in this inhibition term okay a
neuron XJ can only contribute to this
inner
taury you know effect in the circuit if
it's activation is above some threshold
data
okay so weekly active neurons you know
human deflector rating around zero
cannot contribute an admission to the
circuit and only the strong ones down
okay and so that's the idea and just to
say that you know this restores the
regime you know even a very large end of
the possibility of winner-take-all
dynamics and much more interesting Leah
so okay so I'll confess that for the
stochastic case with this nonlinear
inhibition we have no analytical results
so I cannot tell you that asymptotically
in the strict limit of n going to
infinity there will be a solution but I
can say that at least for very large and
numerically there is still a very robust
solution and in fact there we don't need
to fine-tune theta so that's all I can
say but I would love to talk about
whether it's possible to say something
analytical for the stochastic and
nonlinear inhibition case it just
becomes difficult with the two
nonlinearities yeah yeah so again I
don't know I mean though it becomes like
a whole universe of nonlinearities to
explore um I I don't know we can discuss
again that's that's something we can
discuss yeah so I want to just pursue
because actually have yeah a few minutes
and I want to talk about these results
and then another set of results for
small in okay because those are relevant
for the psychophysics of decision making
okay so so the the more interesting
thing okay so the first basic thing is
that this nominee or inhibition actually
restores the possibility to do
winner-take-all dynamics with large N
and noisy inputs okay and secondly this
nonlinear inhibition circuit performs
the operation with an accuracy and speed
that matches the parallelism benchmark
okay so in other words if you look at
the decision time as a function of n you
will see that the winner-take-all
network has a scaling this is a semi-log
plot these curves are log n in time and
they compare with this benchmark
strategies which are also log n over
here and in fact the amount this is I
actually absolute amount of time you can
see that they
not only match and scaling like they're
both logged their login compared to the
the best case the benchmark but in fact
even numerically there's only a
discrepancy of like a factor of two or
three in the absolute amount of time it
takes as well okay so I think that's
pretty interesting so this is speed at
fixed accuracy you can also ask the
question of if you just fix the speed
then what is the accuracy and you can
see that you know if we fix the speed
then the accuracy curve for the
benchmark strategy is this purple curve
and in turn the accuracy for the for the
knurl strategy is this - okay and okay
and just to say okay you should be
shocked that the this dash curve is
actually above the purple curve and
that's because actually we've given the
neural network a factor of three more
time
so this dash curve is at a fixed speed
fixed amount of time but a factor of
three times more than this purple curve
to try to match them our kya somatically
and that's why the network strategies
actually looks like it's doing better
than the benchmark it can't be but it
just has three times more time okay so
okay so now what else is interesting so
the other thing I forgot to say is that
we can efficient networks besides not
even succeeding in the stochastic task
you know don't so we don't sorry we can
efficient networks succeed in the
stochastic tasks but they require fine
tuning and they're slow and in addition
they don't show speed accuracy
trade-offs okay but this network this
nonlinear inhibition network with strong
inhibition actually exhibits speed
accuracy trade-off so this is a speed
versus accuracy and you can see that
these curves exhibit a trade-off in
speed and accuracy and in fact
interestingly the performance of these
networks exhibit some kind of a form of
stochastic resonance so if you look at
this plot where this is the amplitude of
noise Sigma ADA that's injected into
each item on the list you can see that
fer if we look if we just go across a
slice here okay of you know so as to be
very noise and keep a fixed end over
here just go across then it turns out
that the network actually has and this
is an accuracy plot so then the accuracy
is hi and then for some noise it gets a
low and then the accuracy gets high
again okay it's like this form of weird
stochastic resonance or just some
intermediate noise at which it does
poorly but then a higher noise actually
does better that it's about your head
that's really weird it turns out that
actually these networks have this very
nice and interesting self adjusting
behavior to their dynamics so basically
when the noise that's being injected
increases in amplitude then the decision
time increases so this is time plot you
can see that the decision time is
increasing with the amount of injected
noise and so they're sort of flexibly
adjusting how long they wait an average
the input as a function of the amount of
noise that's injected and also actually
as a function of N which is the network
site so the network said the self
adjusting but dynamics where you don't
need to tune parameters when you change
the noise amplitude or change the size
of the decision task they they self
adjust okay so I want to just now finish
by just telling you something about the
small anyways so the small in case where
there's just a few like handful of
alternatives up to ten corresponds to an
example or a model of multi alternative
fourth choice decision-making which is
studied very often by many people in the
audience including beautiful work by
charging on like you know decision
making using psychophysics where in
primate psychophysics experiments so
what's interesting is that like in the
large end case if we look at decision
time as a function of n in a small and
regime then we find that the decision
time scales up as the log of n plus one
at least this is the the curve is the -
is that is the simulations and the black
is this fit to this function over here
and in fact the accuracy remains high
all these values and the reward grade
meaning the the product of accuracy x
inverse decision time which is the
reward rate is something that is is very
close in this network with this dashed
line compared to a benchmark strategy
okay so so this network I mean I I just
want to rush through it a bit faster
to the other sides but basically the
network is closely matching this
parallelism benchmark which is a non
leaky accumulation strategy for decision
making and in fact it does it with
completely fixed parameters so now I'm
not even talking about no parameter
fine-tuning here we can just fix the
parameters alpha and beta in the network
and then vary N and the network has a
near optimal performance for all choices
of n because of these self adjusting
dynamics okay and so what's interesting
about that result for small n is a law
called Hicks law that's been observed
you know for I guess how old is o'clock
something like um like hundred years or
so yeah it's like 100 years old it's um
some result from mr. Hicks I college
experience that go way back and actually
it's law has quite some notoriety not in
neuroscience but actually in the fields
of behavioral economics and product
design and marketing and also web design
and all these things because it turns
out that there was some interesting
experiments in marketing where you know
customers are presented in a supermarket
with a choice of six jams in a display
six flavors of jam and when they're
presented with this choice of six
flavors of jam then although the first
represented with a display of 24 options
of jam and when there are 24 options of
jam and 60% of the passerby stopped for
a taste but only made 3 percent of them
by a jam ok but when they're there only
six jams on display then fewer people
stop by like 40 percent but then about a
third of them actually purchase a job ok
so the idea is that you know like
increasing the number of options makes
decision-making much harder and so you
know that that's why when you have a
product sales you should you should give
fewer numbers of options right and so
again you know again also for like use
of panels and things like that for
pilots there are some very important
design considerations to be made based
on Hicks law so he Clause pretty
notorious and in fact the the the
finding that
mr. hit CAD is that he s this is not
showing up but but the finding is that
Hicks finding was that the time it takes
humans to make a decision for n option
skills like log of n plus Martin okay so
in other words what I just want to say
here is that Hicks law is emerging from
this non-linear inhibition neural
winner-take-all dynamics and because
those dynamics are an example of really
if like full saturation of the
parallelism sort of a benchmark Hicks
law is actually I would argue a symptom
of fully parallel you know efficient
fully parallel computation okay and I'm
gonna skip skip the side but I'm there a
lot of them actually interesting results
on the neural underpinnings like what
the neural responses look like when
these decisions are been made in these
circuits and you know like some work by
Xiaojing and others um they they they
actually explain some counterintuitive
neural findings which is that correct
trials tend to converge faster than
incorrect trials which is a feature of
attractor models like the
winner-take-all dynamic circuit is an
attractor model and also interesting the
asymptotic level of the winning choice
the activity level of neurons in the
winning choice is actually higher in to
speed pressure so meaning if you force a
system to be to make a faster decision
the the level to which the neural
activity rises to attack some tonic
value that level is actually higher
under speed pressure and actually that
goes against a lot of other you know
phenomenological models but it's seen an
experiment and this is what this model
exhibits as well so okay so I'll just
stop and by summarizing so neural
winner-take-all bit strong on your
mission fully officially trades on face
for time achieving and in speed up
relative with optimal serial strategies
nonlinear and prevents weakly active
principal cells from computing and
inhibition and that allows even in the
presence of noise for a winner to
actually take off and win this
competition and the this circuit does
not require any parameters fine tuning
remarkably for either fixed end or even
as and varies and it's because of these
self adjusting dynamics to noise a
number of options so it's sort of like
automatically figures out what that is
we presume six law and then the question
is
you know he this this computation that I
described was in the context of a neural
network but it has very simple elements
right this just a global inhibition and
the self-excitation these are so generic
and so simple that you know the question
is what which of the principles that
have arisen here and then this this
observation of the importance of
nonlinear Bayesian term could apply to
distributed decision-making in non
neural systems like these Rockets who
are making some very interesting
nonlinear actually actions which is like
once they exchange information for some
time and there's an integration process
but then at one point the foraging ants
start to just physically pick up neurons
in the colony and then move them to the
to the you know the site of some food or
to a new nest site and at that point the
the competition process becomes
extremely nonlinear and then there's a
very strong bias to its choosing that
that nest site so I just thought that
this picking up or it's called tandem
running behavior might be some example
of the second nominee so thank you very
much yeah so if you look at the new
network equation actually turns out that
you know so that so the noise it doesn't
much matter right because you can you
could not in the rates if you put in the
rates it's a different thing but if you
put the noise in the excise if you put
the noise in the excise it would look
similar right but it's true that if you
have the noise and the rates it might be
somewhat different but you know
ultimately the thing is that you know
it's going to go and get filtered and
then you're gonna you it's gonna go
through the filtering and a
non-linearity anyway so you're gonna get
this problem I'm sure that even in that
case the failure of strong inhibition
canonical winner-take-all circuits to
converge at large and it's going to be
still true right and in fact there are
there is a transformation to right
there's like the
the the Grossberg transformation where
you can transform from having the
non-linearity so if you forget about
this nonlinear inhibition part you know
you can transform from having the
non-linearity out here to having a
linear sum and then you know a linear
sum of a set of nonlinear things so I
guess one maybe we can try to work that
out yeah so any questions yeah go ahead
the problem change is when you start
using spiking neurons because of the
non-linearity that basically directly no
that's a great question so I'm very
interested in what happens with spiking
neurons and the reason is because for
many reasons one of them is that you
know here because we're using rates this
is like a high bandwidth communication
right so the neurons are communicating
with each other but the bandwidth is
high and so the question is what happens
when you restrict the bandwidth of the
paralyzed communication between neurons
and so and and and that's also
relatively related to the you know these
ant foraging decisions because each ant
comes in and makes a you know like they
they they have their you know head buds
and will firm when all exchanges and
presumably those are lower bandwidth
communications on the other hand so you
might think that the results could be
quite different spiking neurons and I'm
very interested to know but on the other
hand because of the architecture of this
network
all these excitatory neurons are sending
their outputs to one inhibitory
interneuron that's an inhibiting all of
them so even if the bandwidth if each of
those channels is low ultimately it's
all convergence to one pool and a sum so
the low bandwidth of each of those may
not matter because we're just pulling
we're not actually we don't care about
the detailed N squared signals in the
network we really it's really just one
sum so maybe the limited bandwidth
actually doesn't have an effect so I've
given you both sides and I don't know
what the answer yeah this non-linearity
drive to the auditory network is really
exactly what seen in criminal cell input
to somatostatin
neurons which are doing the recurrent
inhibition because that's still pending
synapse yes great yes exactly
oh I'm so glad you said that yeah
exactly I had this mode to myself like
discuss the mechanism and I didn't so
that's right so what okay so um great
and the other possibility is also like
if you just have inter neurons that are
coincidence and in texture detectors and
so then they only respond to you know
coincident spikes which means like a
high rate input rather than a lower rate
input so those are the two mechanisms
that we could think of for that but
thank you for that yeah yeah no the
second part was okay great yes the
second part was the first part was more
about like the map you know a box for
inference for example even across all
the neurons in a circuit so large and
small and yeah you started bringing in
[Music]
you're going to change gear because we
have causal things like attention start
keeping it yes
that you
relatives work so if you're going to if
you go to the games to decisions which
are within the sampling speed of
consciousness you're going to have to
change what you're doing yeah I I agree
I mean but that's certainly true I mean
I think whenever you know one starts
thinking about things like you know
decision making even short-term memory
on time skills that are long enough
there are all these strategies and
mechanisms that are additional that
could kick in and so I can just say that
the modest thing is that we're not
accounting for all of that we're just
saying if you ignore all those processes
what scaling would you expect this is
the scaling you would expect you could
ask well what which should change if you
include some of those processes yes okay
so not quite a hundred years ago resolve
assumes that you comment and verify out
here is correct yeah that's correct so
here I guess or the Delta of the gap or
increasing the noise you can do any of
those things yeah no so it turns out
that not yeah so yeah that's a good
question I should go back and check when
it breaks down but it's true that once
you start getting away from high
accuracy the scaling also doesn't hold
anymore so that's that's a good point we
should check that yeah you're up
[Music]
keeping the accuracy fixed so again we
don't have analytics because you know
this is the this nonlinear network
we don't have analytics on that but I
can say that you know for fixed
parameter settings it seems like what it
does so you know the stochastic
resonance effect I showed you is
actually a sign that once the noise gets
big enough it's actually then sort of
self adjusting to average for too long
because the once the noise gets big
enough it actually the performance gets
better and the reason we can I can show
you that the reason for the performance
improving at high noise is actually like
over averaging so it's actually doing a
little bit better so it's kind of it's
not exactly maintaining fixed accuracy
but I can show you curves with remains
roughly fixed accuracy for a certain
range of noise and then it older
[Applause]